let's start from the beginning you were
uh investigating uh was it a story about
biden's daughter actually biden's diary
a source and by the way most people
don't know that actually biden has a
daughter named ashley
um and there was a diary joe biden has a
daughter named i'm sorry joe biden has a
daughter named ashley and some a source
sent us this this document this diary um
and uh we looked into it i made the
decision not to publish it because i
couldn't verify with 100 certainty that
it was hers i was like 99 or whatever
percent but i wasn't 100
and even if i could verify that it was
ashley biden's diary i couldn't verify
what she wrote in the diary happened she
talked about having inappropriate
showers with her dad whoa does that mean
that she's wow what does that mean and i
felt like you know and by the way
this is this is the crazy part about
this twilight zone dystopian series of
events someone sends me something i try
to corroborate it i'm unable to and i
say well let me try to give this back to
her she wouldn't take it so i give it to
law enforcement what more could a
responsible ethical journalist let alone
human being do
and that's the scary part what ought i
have done yeah what should i have done
but then they raid me
and then people come to my home at six
am i'm not a morning person my first
thought when they
opened up my first thought was sorry to
bang on your table
i'm a show person is how much time do i
have until they break the door down
and i'm waking up i'm pounding i'm
waking up and i'm thinking okay let me
run to the door like in my underwear
and then i go to open and then before i
turn the door are they going to shoot me
how do i do this in a way where i don't
get killed
and i open the door and there's all
these bright lights and they put me in
handcuffs were you in your underwear yes
i mean i just woken up yeah and
and then they throw me against the
hallway wall outside my apartment my
neighbors are i mean this is i think i'm
not i'm under arrest but for what
what have i done they actually arrest
you and take you they put me in
handcuffs and and then eventually they
showed me a search warrant wow on the
search warrant it listed
i'm not making this [ __ ] up
accessory after the fact
and miss prison of a felony
accessory after the fact these are these
are they haven't been charged with
anything but these are absurd
insinuations of a crime again if it's a
crime
to be sent a document which may or may
not be stolen then you might as well
jail all the journalists in america
so there was a theory james what was
happening here i mean obviously you made
the right moves you went to the
authorities you weren't sure so you
didn't publish you did everything right
here but they still decided to raid you
and and people are theorizing that they
did this because there could have been
federal agents that were the ones that
originally sent you this diary to kind
of set you up to get an excuse to get
into your electronic devices because
they knew potentially someone else was
reaching out to you for a bigger story
that they needed to stop that's one of
the theories out there do you think
that's true because every step of the
way here the feds acted incorrectly
i don't want to speculate i don't want
to that is a theory is it a pretext is
it a form of intimidation i mean even
the new york times reporter mike schmidt
was like
stumbling and bumbling and fumbling on
msnbc when asked what did they really
raid the home if it wasn't actually by a
diary
a diary
so
it's just it's just so crazy there's no
answers does that does that authenticate
the diary then
i would i would think so and that then
implicates uh uh
well then you've got witness
corroboration if the diary is true about
inappropriate behaviors with children
from president joe biden
wouldn't be the first time there have
been these insinuations i've seen the
videos either
they're
persistent uh james i do want to say
that i think you made the right decision
in passing up on uh the contents of the
diary when you were originally in
possession of it
what i tell young journalists and new
journalists is that if you cannot 100
verify
something you don't report it out
correct even on even on that one percent
of doubt and that means often you miss
out on
scoops that end up being accurate that
other people pick up and it's
unfortunate and it's disappointing when
that happens but
um i i wish the new york times had your
standards cnn and msnbc because they'll
just say like you know source says i i
love when they'll say like a source
close to donald trump's
familiar with the matter people familiar
with trump's thinking have said he is he
wants to beat children or something
insane
the new york times andy new york times
did a story about the they published the
attorney client memos and a judge in new
york has done the extraordinary act of
telling them to sequester those
attorney-client memos and the new york
times wrote a headline that said
documents show how far
deceptive reporting practices could go
before running afoul of federal laws do
you know another way to say that we
checked with lawyers to make sure
everything we were doing was legal
but do you see how they worded it they
it's not so much that they lie it's that
they use this sort of
you have to like twist the newspaper
article a little bit to know what
they're saying they don't
say what's false they omit
and so so that that statement's true
right but it's framing it's framing it
in a
fairy it sounds like we we skirted the
law
and that's the scariest part about this
whole ordeal because it was a little
terrifying is that what was i supposed
to do
you think do i hindsight right what more
could we have done we even called we
even contacted the biden campaign and
tried to ask for comment but the new
york times framed that as leverage we
tried to leverage the diary and then
rachel maddow said we tried to extort
the president
so a request for comment becomes
leverage becomes extortion do you see
how the game is played
and and it's very terrifying at times i
will i will say too not not to derail
too much but uh you know cnn's ratings
are down 90 percent
they're in the key demo they barely get
viewers at all it's probably just hotel
lobbies so i don't know if that's any
consolation it's probably not but i when
rachel maddow talks and and these
stories break
i don't know if it's gonna matter in
five or ten years because they're losing
yes but when you have a dying animal
they usually act the most violent right
before they die well and that's what
they're doing they're giving up all of
their standards yes and then when we
look at you know the state it isn't in
in a place that's extremely vulnerable
the official story the official
narrative that they told us for two
years now is breaking shattering right
in front of our face and then people are
realizing hey we were lied to throughout
recorded human history whenever there's
pandemics usually it leads to civil
unrest so there's a big probability that
this is going to happen here and i think
they're trying to hit the mole with the
hammer as much as they can there's a lot
of moles popping up but i think there's
there's uh a lot of anger by this within
minutes the the handcuffs were still my
wrists were still sore
within minutes of this happening i got a
text message from mike schmidt at the
new york times national security
reporter how the hell does he know
the contents of a secret grand jury
subpoena and why the hell are they
leading me to the execution chamber i'm
on the same team as these people we are
supposed to be speaking without fear or
favor which was the quote from adolf aux
or whatever his name was the founder of
the new york times i'll just i'll just
mention project veritas had one of the
most important
bits of uh one of the most important
stories probably by generation the abc
amy rohrbach story with epstein which
contributed to this major uh
investigation which ultimately i think
the maxwell case is kind of being
covered up we can get into that stuff
but uh veritas that's not partisan
when you report on this story saying
this is a a journalist saying i had the
interview i had the story and i didn't
get out that was exposing powerful
establishment elites covering up a very
serious
scandal as an understatement that's
right but why is the new york times
going after you
is it you know it's not it's not just
the new york times i mean it is it is
all of these news outlets that falsely
frame everything about veritas in an
effort to harm you when uh you're doing
stories about you know powerful
corporations and it's also journalists
should be on your side and it's also all
the social media companies right i have
come after you and they recently
pulled one of your employees off as well
eric sprackler in the room exactly
although i will say and i want andy to
get in here but we've trended on twitter
almost every story we've done the last
story we did last week on the pentagon
papers department of defense documents
which effectively are pentagon papers
trended number one on twitter i'm banned
on twitter project veritas is banned on
twitter but what do you think well it's
it's not a side detail that uh
an agent of the state uh is working with
media organizations um to
be the first to break these stories that
are extremely damaging where
you know you don't have to be charged
with any crimes it's the investigation
and the reporting and media coverage on
it that destroys reputations and what
happened to james here with how
while uh he still had marks on his hand
from the handcuffs he's getting requests
from the press for comment when nobody
else knows about it obviously
agents of the state is uh working with
the journalists and leaking information
similarly when when roger stone was
arrested and cnn had been tipped off
with the helicopter i think i i just
let's just say you know when you look at
despotic regimes and tin pot uh
democracies like these are like
characteristics of it
i mean this is disturbing and i i don't
i i
it surprises me that so much of the
american public just kind of shrugged
their shoulders and
you know
praise these uh media organizations when
i i mean i'm thinking right now you know
with with the the the states you know
colluding with these these big media
companies to cover up malfeasance and
corruption
it it's it sounds fascistic and i just
wish there was maybe some organization
maybe that was called like something
opposed to fascism like like no fascism
or maybe anti anti-fascism would call it
anti-fucking shorts
and they would stand up to this kind of
collusion between state and massive
powerful private enterprise yeah where
where is that at where where is the
actual and i know obviously doe we know
antifa's but i'm like where's the actual
opposition from from activists
to say
you know this is a bad thing that being
said i will stress james you did get
defended by some of these institutions
like the aclu they did because they
crossed the line so far yeah even the
aclu was like well i guess we have to
say so one of the things that the i hate
to put it in left right terms because
increasingly this seems to be good
versus evil and i don't necessarily
think those lines are clear but
the left tends to overplay their hand
they tend to take it too far and ends up
biting them in the ass that was a
beautiful moment when ben smith at the
new york times and if ben is watching
this ben smith media columnist new york
times defended me he was the first
person this was a few days afterwards
and he says
journalists should not be cheerleading
this if you look at that tweet he got
ratioed hardcore
no put that o'keefe in jail they don't
care they just want to jail jail there
and people who say lock her up and all
that like i feel like
are we so manichaean that we need to
jail people who disagree with us no
but ben defended me and after ben did he
gave all these other people the
permission to do so aclu society you
know all these organizations um and by
the way ben smith is leaving the new
york times why is he doing that great
question and we can i can also report to
you that there's kind of a schism inside
the new york times well it's not the
first time i mean the the major schism
happened when tom cotton's op-ed ran and
it destroyed the op-ed section of new
york times barry weiss left that's right
the whole newsroom got shaken up um that
was an insane thing that happened that
tom cotton
saying that
the federal government should intervene
in cities and deal with the civil unrest
that was happening um that broke the new
york times it broke the new york times
and the editorial page editor whose name
escapes me uh uh one we released on a
deposition tape
james bennett i have a posse i have my
entourage here we always travel with an
entourage probably very nice uh james
bennett was actually a pretty moderate
guy yeah he wasn't yeah and they made
them out to be a devil so i can report
to you because i have sources
anonymous sources well
people i've covertly recorded i haven't
released yet
who have told me there is a schism there
but tim that was a beautiful moment in
in my life watching people who
hate us i think there still is some
principle there still is some overlap
between the left and right in our
society they're they're i think there's
there
it's probably a bit reductive or um
maybe simplistic but there's two big
camps when it comes to whatever's going
out the establishment people who are
willfully lying and manipulative for
power and people who are blindly going
along and maybe just scared so there's
probably a lot of people who saw what
happened with the new york times and tom
cotton's op-ed and they're like i just
want to get through this the problem i
have with these people it was uh clifton
duncan tweeted something i'm probably
gonna screw it up but he said that he's
less concerned about those that are
overtly engaged in malfeasance and evil
he's more concerned about those who know
what's going on but won't speak up
i saw that too i thought that was really
fascinating and made a lot of sense
right well the new york times are also
being kind of eaten up by hedge funds
and the people who truly own them i
think this is why jeff bezos bought the
washington uh times because washington
washington post excuse me uh because
people are understanding this this quote
by lord northcliff when he said quote
news is what somebody somewhere wants to
suppress all the rest is advertising
these people are buying advertising
they're buying pr they're buying favors
for themselves literally trying to
brainwash the american public so their
agenda their narrative will pass and
clear no matter how absurd they still
push these ideas because these ideas are
way more important than even the money
that they put into these institutions
that they're losing what's so
fascinating about that though is so
we're at the post-millennial
we
you know i kind of think of us as the
antidote to fear right we're not
corporate uh we're a small outlet you
know andy and i run stories there all
the time um and what's really
interesting is that we're getting
attacked you know we get attacked by
these activists who are saying that we
are aligned with specific interests and
we're not they're defending the big
outlets the big corporate media outlets
that are aligned with specific interests
and here we are just like you know
covering news stories covering what we
think is interesting trying to get the
truth out there and they attack us
for doing that well jeff bezos bought
the washington post in 2013 and after
google and facebook snatched up most of
these advertising models hedge funds
like alden global capital everything's
been consolidated newspapers are gone
investigative journalism is gone abc
news cut their whole investigative
bureau and jeff bezos in an
extraordinary admission
of the power of narrative amplified
through big tech through his ownership
the washington post said quote on a
medium post
my ownership of the post is something i
will be most proud of when i'm 90 and
reviewing my life not his rocket dr evil
rocket ship company not his washington
not not his amazon company no no his
ownership the washington post is his
biggest achievement and i found that
really a amazing
insight into the power of narrative i
think the washington post and the new
york times i may be giving them too much
credit are more powerful
than all three branches of government
because government speaks through them
big tech prefers them in their
algorithms big tech doesn't do any
journalism they just prefer what do you
think wait did bezos say that before he
became a space man
yes with his wiener rocket he's not
proud of his wiener rocket yeah although
he was formulating that but just one
extra point here it's not just hedge
funds it's not just just jeff bezos it's
also bill gates that donates hundreds of
millions of dollars to the corporate
media they don't they don't need
donations but they willingly take it and
with that money of course comes the
narrative that they push
if you're if you're one of the higher
ups these companies and i've seen this
firsthand and you're looking at your
bottom line you don't care about the
politics of the individual person
writing stories you just don't want to
lose money the guys who run the
businesses don't care about news i've
when i was at that abc news company that
abc new fusion their attitude from the
at the higher level was what are we
going to get clicks on so hire the
people who write about the things you
think will get clicks the marketing guys
then said we got to do woke stuff that's
the way forward okay then hire young
woke people and tell them to write about
what they care about they didn't they
didn't care if it was real they didn't
care i was told
what a side with the audience they said
side with the audience that means if
there is a news story that is factual
but will be offensive to the audience we
don't cover it that's that's the modern
uh like i mentioned the new york times
or i should say to to quote i think it
was
sargon that the new york times has found
their audience they've said screw
everybody else and that's what they're
going for but that's what almost every
organization does especially right now i
don't care i don't care who they are
90 of all media outlets are like we've
got an audience and we're going to cater
to that audience that's the wrong that's
the inverse of what they ought to be
doing right there's a journalist named
clarence jones and he wrote when he
wrote about journalism that journalistic
publishers need to be like bosses with
balls they need to have integrity at
veritas we're a non-profit people say
what's your business model we have you
know eight hundred thousand people give
us money sometimes a dollar sometimes
ten thousand dollars but we choose the
hardest stories and we don't settle
lawsuits because
and this is the real crux of this book
american muckraker secrecy transparency
we don't settle lawsuits tim because i
don't fear people inspecting my
operation please do depose me i like
being deposed they don't like being
deposed because when they enter
discovery process of litigation you can
see all the lies under oath did you guys
know that uh
donald trump at his rally in arizona
banned fjb icons and merchandise and
shirts and all that stuff
yep i got no problem we have that on
timcast.com we have a full report where
the security guy's telling people to
take their shirts off take their hats
off you know so people will say that you
know this show or me or trump supporters
or right wing i think the splc was like
tim poole is a right wing you know
something or other who supports trump
and i'm like uh
no i just don't lie about him like
luke's criticism amazingly respectful of
what trump did i really respect that
that he banned it i mean and a lot of a
lot of trump supporters did well he said
this he said i don't like that but he
had four years of people saying that to
him as the president and i think he
probably knows how much that sucks to be
like in charge of everything and have
people keep saying like you know fdt at
you all the time yeah but he said this
he said this on the heels right after
saying that it's hard to criticize joe
biden because joe biden complimented him
on all the work that he did with the
vaccine well but right but but that's
sort of a that's a different situation i
mean and also let's not forget like
donald trump was a president he was
holding executive office
uh
has there ever been a president who's
really worthwhile i mean come on like
this is i think they should be
criticized for the full extent
i agree too that's the point i don't
want to but i respect a pres a former
president saying don't say that about
the current president but the i respect
that the the important issue
i guess i'm trying to get to is
what the media is willing to say
who they're willing to criticize how
often does cnn run you know joe biden
has screwed this up screwed that up
screw this up they did they what was it
trump's coverage was 98 percent negative
and don't get me wrong there is a lot of
negative coverage coverage about joe
biden and i think what happens is around
august of last year when we saw this
flip in approval rating like you were
mentioning once someone says something
it makes it okay for the establishment
or for the for the you know whatever you
want to call it democratic position for
the most part all of a sudden people
start ragging on biden and then we see
some articles popping up where they're
like oh okay maybe there's something
here but for the most part the media is
unwilling to step out of line with their
own audience and most um some of that's
economics and some of that is because
they there's been a proximity to their
sources they don't want to bite the hand
that feeds them
and that's the difference between sort
of the journalism that we're talking
about in american muckraker and their
their journalism is to represent be the
ombudsman for
the the so-called administrative state
our whistleblowers release information
the administration
ministry of state does not want revealed
that missed all the difference in the
world when a two-star general talks to
the new york times via anonymously we
don't know the cadence or intonation of
what that we don't know
what what that person is actually trying
to say and now they throw out these
terms misinformation and disinformation
we've talked about the new york times
lawsuit that i'm in brooklyn which is
fascinating because the new york times
admitted tim in the response to our
defamation lawsuit they got the facts
wrong and they still haven't corrected
the article they admitted in court they
got it wrong the guy had more than three
ballots they said it wasn't illegal they
admitted in court it was and the article
remains online uncorrected have there
been had there been any fact checkers on
this one has the new york times facebook
traffic been suppressed as a result the
new york times thinks they're above the
law no i'm sure they think they're i say
you know dean back kay famously
executive out of new york times dean
beckham says we don't get religion the
new york times thinks they're god yes
they don't
what
force or or
organization on planet earth can hold
the new york times accountable can
anyone they lie no one cares
google and twitter prefer them in the
algorithms i sue them i sued them we
sued them for defamation and won a
victory and they still haven't corrected
the article in fact they're attacking
the judge personally and viciously yeah
which is something you shouldn't do by
the way i i was surprised to see that to
be honest because you're gonna make the
judge rule against you but the new york
times is probably thinking in the short
term yeah we'll probably piss the judge
uh judge off in the long term he won't
he won't retain power and if it goes to
the court of appeals highest court in
new york state they don't care and if it
goes to the supreme court and they lose
they'll say trump court think of it
there's nothing that can hold them
accountable and i think that i think
that they are more afraid than i am of
them i i know that to be true
but this term misinformation tim
i think it's really about distrusting
people to draw the acceptable conclusion
based upon facts that are admittedly
true
i don't think it's about untrue facts
anymore thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you